let me ask you this this is random have
you made it to detroit
since
you're right i'm not sitting no but i've
been to detroit many times all this
stuff is going on okay i just yeah
everyone's like you got to go to a coney
island while you're in detroit yeah yeah
and i was like isn't that a place in
brooklyn yeah so we went to the coney
islands in detroit
it's hot dogs yeah but it's so crazy
that it's like so embedded into the
culture of detroit everybody did so
around the early 2000s when i was
battling doing the fight club [ __ ] and
all that i was [ __ ] with d12 heavy
bizarre proof rest in peace so i was
going out there
uh
numerous times but the first time i went
out there i'm like it's everywhere it's
a cornea i'm like yo why all these
stores say coney island on them what the
[ __ ] is this
and then i would go and i would be like
oh these are hot dogs so nathan's
inc which is like a original place in
coney and coney they invented kind of
like hot dogs that's where that's there
that's all i guess they could just not
be [ __ ] guzzling all these [ __ ]
blizzy gladiators
so i guess they couldn't they didn't
want to i guess whoever created these
stores or started doing the coney
islands didn't want to pay nathan's
defeat and was just like oh [ __ ] nathan
who's just going to call it coney island
yeah it's like embedded out there but it
was like you got to go to a coney island
every neighborhood has their own yeah
it's crazy it's wild yeah and they use
it as like a noun yeah yeah they don't
call the hot dogs they call it like you
gotta you gotta go to the coney island
go go find you a good coney island i'm
like and then they got everything in
there they got hot dogs they got [ __ ]
pancakes yeah
what do you want yo what are you what
are you eating i'm eating a coney it's
just like yo what the [ __ ] it's embedded
heavily out there 100 it's pretty crazy